großveranstaltung
darauf haben sich die länder gestern
geeinigt großveranstaltungen normale
veranstaltung auch nicht erlaubt ist
wird man dann immer wieder regelmäßig
überprüfen großveranstaltung bis zum
31.08 nicht möglich ich werde die
nächsten zwei wochen mit dem
oberbürgermeister von münchen ein
intensives gespräch machen wir beide
sind aber sehr skeptisch
auch das oktoberfest überhaupt möglich
ist und wir in den nächsten zwei wochen
entscheidung treffen
aus heutiger sicht bin ich da sehr sehr
skeptisch kann mir das ehrlich gesagt
nicht vorstellen aber wir wollen es den
seriöserweise entscheiden die einzige
veranstaltung die wir ab mai für möglich
halten sind gottesdienste
dort verdient gespräche mit den kirchen
statt über kluge konzepte mit
möglicherweise mehreren gottesdienst an
einem tag vor allem eine größeren
kirchen um den abstand so zu
organisieren dass hygienische anspruch
aber das ist grund richtig wichtig
geschützte recht religionsausübung
möglich ist